we got sergeant john bazalone
u.s marine corps guadalcanal 1942.
august 1942
the first marine division landed on
guadalcanal encountering stiff
resistance from the japanese defenders
sergeant john basilone served as a
machine gun platoon sergeant in support
of
company c first battalion seventh
marines
on the night of 24 october sergeant
basilone's platoon
occupied a key position in the
battalion's offensive perimeter on a
jungle ridge
just past 2130 the japanese began a
ferocious attack
in the dark rainy night intense fighting
followed and
soon the machine gun unit on basilone's
right was overrun by screaming japanese
soldiers
hurling grenades and firing rifles
at the same time basilone's machine guns
started running low on ammunition
basilone knew that the enemy that had
broken through on his right were between
him and the ammunition dump
but he decided that if his gun teams
were not resupplied
the positions would fall sergeant
bazillon
took off his heavy mud caked boots
stripped himself of all unnecessary gear
and sprinted
down the trail after returning with
several belts of ammunition
he set out for the unmanned machine gun
pits to his right knowing that those
heavy weapons were vital
tools in the defense of the ridge when
he got back to the gun
positions he found two unoccupied
machine guns
jammed and ran back to get one of his
own he ordered a team to follow him
after bazillon's gun crew reached their
destination he immediately put them into
action
basilone lay on the ground and began
repairing one of the damaged weapons
once the gun was repaired and loaded he
got behind the gun and began engaging
targets
the fight raged on and japanese bodies
began to pile up in front of the machine
guns
at one point sergeant basilone had to
direct his marines to push back the
piles of bodies
to maintain clear fields of fire
several more times during the night
sergeant basilone made trips
back to the command area for desperately
needed ammunition
eight separate attacks were sent against
the marines that night
and basilone's platoon fired over 25
000 rounds
they were credited with killing an
estimated 300 enemy soldiers
playing a major role in thwarting the
japanese attack
this successful defense re-established
the perimeter of the first marine
division
protected the vital airfield and led to
the conquest of guadalcanal
the first island taken from the japanese
for his initiative resourcefulness and
leadership
in defense of the ridge sergeant
basilone was awarded
the medal of honor
lessons tactically sergeant basilone
understood his role in the defense of
the ridge and the intent of the company
and battalion commanders
his machine gun served a pivotal role in
the company and battalion defense line
plan he took numerous actions necessary
to
ensure his battalion's success this
included making the decision to weaken
one position in order to fortify
an adjacent unit's position to his right
sergeant bazalone exhibited great
leadership during the defense
he went to great lengths to provide his
unit with whatever tools were necessary
to maintain the defense of the ridge
his courage in braving enemy fire to
deliver ammunition
set an example for his marines
unbelievable it's it's interesting
when you think about their low on
ammunition
and his decision is i'm
going to get i'm going to go personally
get the ammunition
and i can see a couple factors playing
into that decision
one of them being if we don't have ammo
we're all going to die
so it doesn't matter you know i could
send another guy
but and i could stay here to try and
help you know
maintain our position but without
without ammunition we're all going to
die
so the number one thing we need
is ammunition and these guys know what
they're doing they got this
but without bullets we're going to get
overrun i'm going to do this
that's uh it's an interesting thing
because
you know sometimes leaders got to say
okay this is what's going on here's the
absolutely critical task and i'm
actually just going to go do it right
now
because if it doesn't get done we're all
doomed
taking off his boots
that's a that's a hard
thing for me to think about because my
feet are soft
man i think every time we turned on
basilone road you know up there at camp
pendleton going our
ranges and and training uh you just
think about
think about uh you know the exploits of
john basil that's that's incredible i
you know i think the other thing too to
think about here is these other these
other illustrations we're looking at i
mean obviously amazing illustrations of
a junior leader you know squad leader
stepping up and making these calls but
you know the previous ones in world war
one and two you were talking about you
know
look vicious fighting obviously people
are dying and and being
uh you know shot and blown up or banded
or whatever but
those particular charges bonsai charges
like that in in uh
in guadalcanal like there's zero
quarters going to be given so you're
overrun and like everyone's gonna get
killed
and and i think uh you know i think that
was uh
it's a different situation you know uh
and i think a lot more desperation there
you can't just throw up your hands and
surrender like the germans did to
sergeant your corporal york in that
particular situation
yeah i mean i almost didn't even make it
past the sentence in the dark rainy
night intense fighting followed and soon
the machine gun unit on bazalon's right
was overrun by screaming
japanese soldiers hurling grenades and
firing rifles
just dark and
when you're in dark and especially in a
jungle like that and it's dark outside
and then you shoot your gun and now
you've seen the muzzle flash
like you can't you can't see anything
now like it's dark it's black
and so now the only thing you're hearing
is screaming
japanese they're throwing grenades which
again is ruining your night vision
you're seeing muzzle flashes you're
shooting back at muzzle flashes
freaking just horror it's just horror
yeah that's some unbelievable heroism
there
i i think you're hitting on a good point
though about prior the prioritizing
execute piece
and i think you know we generally would
say leaders don't want to be down on the
details you want to be detached but
you know to your point if you in the
prioritized and execute scene if i don't
go do this now
none of it matters we have to do that
and uh
it's the existential priority yeah if if
we don't
execute this priority we will not exist
anymore it's an
existential decision and there's only
you look and he probably looked
said you know i got this guy he's
working that gun he can do that
there's one person that could actually
make this happen right now and it's me
i'll be back in seven minutes with some
ammo fellas
bazzy